oui alors patin mais ce n'est qu'ils
pourront alors répond toujours aux ptt
tu vois les toiles acquérir un peu
madame dubois font vite fait un raconte
un peu à moi je rentre la lie contre
infinie médaillés plus bourré je crois
que c'était la guerre dans les gares
pour hisser toujours les plus belles un
coup c'est une embuscade la blessure la
loire puis l'autre coup c'est le poignon
et surtout leygnac briques
et bien que oui
c'est ainsi que les facteurs partent en
guerre et que charles aznavour en
compagnie de pierre mondy tourner sous
la direction de jacques bernard aubert
les péripéties d'un facteur parisien il
n'est pas toujours aussi facile de
livrer le courrier en pleine nature
et il ya tout à parier que notre facteur
préfère encore les embarrasse paris à la
brousse quand votre gêne même s'ils sont
quelquefois plus dense
j'avoue on n'a pas tellement l'habitude
de vouloir un facteur qu'est ce qui se
passe et affiche tagolsheim gages mais
rarement venu uniquement pour les
besoins du film le vainqueur sur des
barrières et qu'est ce que c'est que le
facteur 100 atteint m
c'est un film d'action notant qu'un film
give final dramatique un film comique
muguet une action quand on parle de
charles aznavour sur l'habitude d'avoir
un titre de chanson qui suivent et
qu'est ce que vous en pensez alors parce
que là cet acteur est absolument pas
chantèrent cheville est totalement le
monde de la chanson pendant tout le
temps que j'ai fait ce film
ce qui m'a pris d'avoir beaucoup de
temps et j'ai doublé de pension
personnelle et des mauvaises langues
enfin je suis passé sont des mauvaises
langues qui disent que charles aznavour
c'est d'avoir un homme de fer alors
c'est les mauvaises langues
est-ce que vous qu'est ce que vous
pensez que vous êtes un e faire un
acteur méchant que je pense que c'est
aux gens de juger je chante tout le nez
je fais un film pendant deux mois
j'écris mes chansons à quel moment
pensez vous que je puisse faire des
affaires
tu vous une question d'un revêtement
idiote allez-y sadove cet habitué de
voir à ce genre de questions tête
et qu'est ce que vous pensez enfin
quelle impression pensez vous pouvez
faire une brave dame si vous aviez un
matin tenu au moment des fêtes de noël
du jour de l'an pour le fait qu'elle
envoyée je pense que j essaie de nous il
me rappelle quelqu'un et ressemble à
quelqu'un mais je sais pas qui